so i've been getting a bunch of emails
from people saying david you've got to
talk about the crypto crash is crypto
over have you sold your crypto what is
going on here
and indeed the crypto markets have had a
significant downturn
that started about 12 days ago 12 14
days ago when elon musk announced on
twitter
that tesla will not continue to invest
in nor will they
accept bitcoin for the sale of tesla
vehicles
due to the hefty environmental cost of
mining bitcoin
this exploded into a lot of arguments
about that environmental cost
and it immediately caused the decline in
the value of bitcoin
this was then compounded over the
weekend as china's crackdown
on bitcoin and cryptocurrency has
rattled
confidence i guess we would say in the
crypto markets
so i'm going to be giving you my take on
this which will not be financial advice
it will just be what i am doing and how
i see it as someone who has held bitcoin
and other cryptos for
a period of many years at this point in
time i want to
mention that this video is produced in
partnership with policy
genius buying life insurance can be
complicated you often don't
know how much coverage you need what it
should cost
policy genius has reinvented the process
of buying life insurance
to make it easy for you to do it the
right way policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes
from over a dozen top insurers all in
one place
you could save thirteen hundred dollars
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
maybe getting life insurance has been on
your to-do list cross it off the list it
is a relief
to get it done knowing that you and your
loved ones are covered
i went on the website it took me two
minutes to find life insurance quotes
tailored to my
needs when you're ready to apply policy
genius
handles the paperwork and the scheduling
for free
they never sell your information to
other companies you can save
fifty percent on more or more on life
insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius just go to
policygenius.com david pakman show and
get
started so here's the deal i have sold
no crypto during the crash i'm not
one of these hold forever people i'm not
claiming to have so-called diamond hands
but as many of you know uh i don't trade
okay people write to me they say david
you should have sold your tesla stock on
this date and bought back in on this
date and then sold on this date and
bought back in on the
i just don't do that uh as i've said
before with crypto
uh i have determined by reading
financial analyses and reports
that i think it makes sense to have a
few
percentage points of my assets
in cryptocurrency over the last four
years my cryptocurrency holdings have
gone
10x or something like that and during
2021 i've been selling
little tranches of my cryptocurrency
why because it was predictable that at
some point there would be a correction
it could be a permanent correction or it
might just be a temporary correction so
my idea was
let me just get my profits out lock in
my profits
and then i don't really have to worry
about the decline even if it goes to
zero now
i'm good so i'm not moving anything
and that is my strategy and you know
what i'm too busy producing the show
to know oh this is the bottom of this
dip and then here's the top and sell and
then buy and then set a
stop limit or come on guys you know i
don't do that
you know i don't do that and so no i
have not made any moves i have no idea
about the future of the cryptocurrency
space what i see is
although the price of a bitcoin has gone
down
adoption seems to be continuing ways to
shift
to alternative and renewables for mining
are increasingly being discussed there
are more and more big financial firms
advising their clients hey maybe you
hold one or two percent of assets maybe
three percent of assets
in cryptocurrency so for me
and i'm a long-term person nothing
really has changed
is there some concern about the
amount of power that
elon musk alone seems to wield over the
price of bitcoin yes
that is a concern that is a concern but
over the long term i believe that as
adoption increases which i still think
it probably will
um elon musk's influence is going to
diminish
that would be my expectation so i've
really changed no
um uh strategic
points for my holding of cryptocurrency
i consider it extremely risky
it is extremely volatile and i keep it
as a
quite small percentage i think it's
about four percent
of my total assets right now and this is
not advice to anybody anybody has to
figure out what the
what makes sense for them these are
risky investments due due diligence
and i would never advise anyone to buy
sell or do anything
like that just telling you what i'm
doing i am really not paying too much
attention to the day-to-day noise
and i'm sort of curious like where will
it be in two years rather than two
months that's my thought
if you have a different philosophy let
me know i know there are lots of
traitors in the audience that's
a totally different thing that's just
not what i do for me it's a
diversification pla
play and a diversification play alone